you write that quote fascinatingly the
pan psychist interpretation seems to
lead to observations of practical
results to a degree that physics
fundamentalists might call superstitious
reports of long-distance telepathy and
remote causation are ubiquitous in the
general population I am not convinced
says yoshibak that establishing the
empirical reality of telepathy would
force an update of any part of serious
academic physics but it could trigger an
important revolution in both
neuroscience and AI from a circuit
perspective to a coupled complex
resonator
paradigm
are you suggesting that there could be
some
rigorous
uh
mathematical wisdom to pan psychist
perspective on the world
so first of all pan psychism is the
perspective that Consciousness is
inseparable for matter in the universe
and I find pan psychism quite
unsatisfying because it does not explain
Consciousness right it does not explain
how this aspect of matter produces it is
also going to try to formalize pen
psychism and write down what it actually
means and with a more formal
mathematical language it's very
difficult to distinguish it from saying
that there is a software site to the
world in the same way as their software
side to what the transistors are doing
in your computer so basically there's a
pattern at a certain coarse graining of
the universe that in some reasons of the
universe leads to observers that are
observing themselves
right so pen psychism maybe is not even
when I write it down a position that is
distinct from functionalism
but intuitively a lot of people have
that the activity of matter itself of
mechanisms in the world is insufficient
to explain it so it's something that
needs to be intrinsic to matter itself
and
you can apart from this abstract idea
have an experience in which you
experience yourself as being the
universe which I suspect is basically
happening because you manage to dissolve
the division between personal self and
mind that you establish as an infant
when you construct a personal self and
transcend it again and understand how it
works
um but there is something deeper that is
that you feel that you're also sharing a
state with other people that you um
have an experience in which you notice
that your personal self is
moving into everything else that you
basically look out of the eyes of
another person that
um every agent in the world that is an
observer is in some sense you so if we
forget that we are the same agent so is
it that we feel that or do we actually
accomplish it so is telepathy possible
is it real so for me that's just a
question that I don't really know the
answer to in turing's famous 1950 paper
in which he describes the Turing test he
does speculate about telepathy
interestingly and asked himself if
telepathy is real and he thinks that it
variable might be what uh it would be
the implication for AI systems that try
to be intelligent because he didn't see
a mechanism by which a computer program
would become telepathic and I suspect if
telepathy would exist so if all the
reports that you get from people when
you ask the normal person on the street
I find that very often they say I have
experiences with telepathy the
scientists might not be interested in
this and might not have a theory about
this but I have difficulty explaining it
away and so you could say maybe this is
the Superstition maybe it's a false
memory or maybe it's a little bit of
their courses who knows maybe somebody
wants to make their own life more
interesting or misremember something but
a lot of people report I noticed
something terrible happened to my
partner and I know this is exactly the
moment it happened where my child had an
accident and I knew that was happening
and the child was in a different town
right so maybe it's a false memory where
this is later on mistakenly attributed
but a lot of people think this is not
the correct explanation so if something
like this was real what would it mean
it probably would mean that either your
body is an antenna that is sending
information over all sorts of channels
like
um maybe just electromagnetic radio
signals that you're sending over long
distances and you get attuned to another
person that you spend enough time with
to get a few bits out of The Ether to
figure out what this person is doing or
maybe it's also when you are very close
to somebody and you become empathetic
with them what happens that is that you
go into a resonance state with them
right similar to when people go into a
seance and they go into a trend State
and they start shifting a Ouija board
around on the table I think what happens
is that they their minds go by their
nervous systems into a resonance state
in which they basically create something
like a shared dream between them
physical closeness or closeness broadly
defined with physical closeness is much
easier to experience empathy with
someone right it's I suspect it would be
difficult for me to have empathy for you
if you were in a different town also how
would that work but if you are very
close to someone you pick up all sorts
of signals from their body not just via
your eyes but with your entire body and
if the nervous system sits on the other
side and the interstellular
communication sits on the other side and
it's integrating over all these signals
you can make inferences about the state
of the other and it's not just the
personal self that does this via
reasoning but your perceptual system and
what basically happens is that your
interact representations are directly
interacting it's the physical
um
resonant models of the universe that
exist in your nervous system and in your
body might go into resonance with others
and start sharing some of their states
so we basically buy next to a big next
to somebody you pick up some of their
Vibes and uh feel without looking at
them what they're feeling in this moment
and it's difficult for you if you're
very empathetic to detach yourself from
it and have an emotional state that is
completely independent from your
environment people who are highly
empathetic are describing this and now
imagine that a lot of organisms in in on
this planet have representations of the
environment and operate like this and
they are adjacent to each other and
overlapping so there's going to be some
degree in which there is basically some
change interaction and we are forming
some slightly shared representation and
no relatively few neuroscientists who
consider this possibility I think big um
Rarity in this regard is Mac 11 who is
considering these things in earnest
and I stumbled on this train of thought
mostly by noticing that the tasks of a
neuron can be fulfilled by other cells
as well they can send different typed
chemical messages and physical messages
to their adjacent cells and learn when
to do this and why not make this
conditional and become Universal
functional approximators the only thing
that they cannot do is Telegraph
information over axons very quickly over
long distances right so neurons in this
perspective are specially adapted kind
of telegraph cell that has evolved so we
can move our muscles very fast but our
body is in principle able to also make
models of the world just much much
slower
it's interesting though that at this
time at least in human history there
seems to be a gap between the tools of
science
and the subjective experience that
people report like you're talking about
with telepathy and
it seems like
but not quite there no I think that
there is no gap between the tools of
science and telepathy either it's there
it's not and it's an empirical question
and if it's there we should be able to
detect it in a lab so why is there not a
lot of Michael Evans walking around I I
don't think that Michael 11 is uh
specifically focused on telepathy very
much he is focused on self-organization
in living organisms and in brains both
as a paradigm for development and
there's a paradigm for information
processing and when you think about how
organization processing works on
organisms there is first of all radical
locality which means everything is
decided locally from the perspective of
an individual cell the individual cells
the agent and the other one is coherence
basically there needs to be some
Criterion that determines how these
cells are interacting in such a way that
order emerges on the next level of
structure and this principle of
coherence of
imposing constraints that are not
validated by the individual parts and
lead to coherent structure to basically
Transcendent the agency where you form
an agent on the next level of
organization is crucial in this
perspective it's so cool that radical
locality
leads to the emergence of complexity at
the higher layers and I think what Mike
Levin is looking at is is nothing that
is outside of the realm of Science in
any way it's just that he is a
paradigmatic thinker who developed his
own Paradigm and most of the
neuroscientists are using a different
Paradigm at this point and this often
happens in science that a field is has a
few paradigms in which people try to
understand reality and build Concepts
and make experiments you're kind of one
of those type of paradigmatic thinkers